the White House has described
impeachment hearings against US
President Donald Trump as a sham on
Thursday a former Russia expert who
worked under Trump told the inquiry that
a fictional narrative was used to link
Ukraine to interference in the 2016 US
presidential election we'll have more on
Fiona Hills testimony in just a moment
but first here's the White House
statement that came just after
Thursday's hearing in it spokesman Hogan
Gidley said that President Trump wants
to have an impeachment trial in the
Senate because it's clearly the only
chamber where he can expect fairness and
receive due process under the
Constitution he went on to say that we
would expect to finally hear from
witnesses who actually witnessed and
possibly participated in corruption like
Adam Schiff he said Joe Biden hunter
Biden and the so-called whistleblower to
name but a few
a live update from our White House
correspondent in just a few moments but
first al jazeera's Heidi Joe Castro
reports on the latest hearing in Capitol
Hill raise your right hand I will begin
by swearing you in the day's testimony
began with a warning from the former
White House policy expert on Russia and
Ukraine some of you on this committee
appear to believe that Russia and its
security services did not conduct a
campaign against our country and that
perhaps somehow for some reason Ukraine
did this is a fictional narrative that
has been perpetrated and propagated by
the Russian security services themselves
Fiona Hill testified Russia was watching
the impeachment hearings and ultimately
would benefit from Republicans repeating
the quote fictions that Ukraine meddled
in the 2016 elections with the help of
Democrats she said she had warned Gordon
sahlan the EU Ambassador the same when
she realized he was carrying out the
president's personal political agenda by
requesting Ukraine open investigations
into Trump's political rivals and I did
set him ambassador Sunderland Gordon I
think this is all going to blow up and
here we are David Holmes a foreign
service officer in the kiev embassy
testified Ukraine has been cleaning up
corruption under its new president below
Tamir szalinski home said szalinski
wanted an oval office meeting with
from but it was made clear that Solinsky
wouldn't get the meeting unless he
announced on CNN that Ukraine was
investigating Joe Biden this was a
demand that President zelanski
personally commit on a cable news
channel to a specific investigation a
president Trump's political rival Holmes
testified he also had a clear impression
that a hold on US military aid was
likely intended by Trump to pressure
Ukraine for the investigation Holmes
said he overheard a phone call between
Trump and ambassador Shawne hland
discussing whether szalinski would
cooperate
so you heard president Trump ask
ambassador Sandlin is he going to do the
investigation yes sir what was
ambassador sunland's response he said oh
yeah he's gonna do it he'll do anything
you asked that urn Holmes this rebuke
from Republican congressman Mike Turner
your statements that your interests are
protecting Ukraine are very dubious when
you embarrass president szalinski by
making those statements you even have to
make who cares that ambassador
Sutherland said that who cares that
question sums up a Republican defense
strategy to counter these five days of
public testimony that Democrats say show
Trump at best misused his office and at
worst committed bribery but is that
enough to move the American public the
latest polls show that Americans remain
evenly divided on whether to impeach
Trump and remove him from office and the
vast majority say that these hearings
will not change their minds Heidi Joe
Castro al Jazeera Washington all right
let's bring in our White House
correspondent Kimberly Hellcat so it's
been a fascinating week of testimony
Kimberly Kimberly where do things stand
right now yeah Heidi Jo caster just
summed it up pretty well there it really
goes along not just for the American
public but also in the US Congress along
party lines there does seem to be a
belief that there was an established
case put forward by Democrats the
president leveraged
that military aid to Ukraine in order to
seek a political investigation if she
was former Vice President Joe Biden his
political rival but the problem is what
wasn't established is anyone actually
hearing that order and so the argument
from Republicans is you can't impeach a
president based on hearsay now Democrats
say yes you can because there was a
generally implied culture and this is
what the sort of amounts to bribery high
crimes and misdemeanors but regardless
of all of that where things stand the
next step is that the House Judiciary
Committee takes this up drafting the
articles of impeachment it goes to the
broader House of Representatives if
Nancy Pelosi the House Speaker chooses
to do so for debate that would trigger a
trial in the US Senate and as you stated
at the start of the segment that's
something the White House supports
because up till now the White House says
it has not had an adequate opportunity
to defend the president and what's this
we're hearing about another possible
inquiry tell us about that right it
makes your head want to spin another one
since Donald Trump was elected first
there was the Russia inquiry
investigation with Robert Mulder the
special counsel into whether or not
Donald Trump and his campaign in 2016
colluded with Russia okay we have that
one now we have the impeachment inquiry
now it looks like Senator Lindsey Graham
is gearing up for yet another
investigation into something that has
come up throughout this impeachment
inquiry and that is the question of what
former Vice President Joe Biden's son
hunter Biden was doing on an Energy
Board in Ukraine given he didn't have
any qualifications and we did hear from
dr. Fiona hill in the impeachment
inquiry yesterday that in fact she did
find this unusual it would be unusual
Republican or Democrat Republicans have
ceased on that and then there's another
investigation that has been going and we
will be hearing more about that in the
coming weeks as well and it has to do
with the Russia probe and that is a look
into the FBI whether or not it was used
for political purposes Senator Lindsey
Graham also overseeing that one that
will be a report that comes out December
9th another hearing December 11th and
look to the Republicans to really be
on this and the argument that they're
making this is an embattled president
who's been a victim of subsequent
investigations by the Democrats in order
to overturn the outcome of the 2016 US
election did you know that you're gonna
help us try to keep track of all of this
on White House correspondent Kimberly
Hellcat many thanks dick Kimberly well
it's been an explosive week of
testimonies on Tuesday
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander VIN Byrne
testified saying that he heard a phone
call where President Trump made what he
called improper demands of the Ukrainian
president on Wednesday former special
envoy to Ukraine kurt volker told the
hearing that he thought trump's personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani was feeding a
negative narrative of Ukraine and on
Thursday EU Ambassador Gordon Sunderland
said he believed that military aid had
been withheld from Ukraine to pressure
its government into investigating
Trump's rivals that should be Wednesday
I'm sorry Sam Berger is vice president
of democracy and government reform at
the Center for American Progress he was
a senior domestic policy advisor at the
White House during Barack Obama's
presidency he joins us now live from
Washington what did you make of this
rather interesting week Sam well was
certainly an explosive week of testimony
that I think laid out a very clear case
that the president hasn't committed and
P chable offenses perhaps the the most
shocking testimony came over Wednesday
and Thursday first ambassador Gordon
Sandland who was Trump's point person in
Ukraine basically saying that everyone
was in on it the highest reaches of
government were aware of what he was
doing and signing off on it and then the
next day with dr. Fiona Hill coming to
realization almost before our eyes that
what she was doing
namely running a process to protect
American national security was not the
primary focus in Ukraine rather it was
ambassador zomlings efforts to obtain
these investigations to help the
president politically that was at least
the White House is focused with respect
to Ukraine so given all of that why
would the president through his
spokesmen say that he would welcome an
impeachment trial in the Senate
well I think obviously any sort of
statement by this White House has to be
taken with a grain of salt but I think
in part what you saw alluding to was
remember the point of this was to try
and gin up investigations in order to
help the president politically and what
he's suggesting is he'd like to use the
Senate to do just that
basically to attack his political rivals
through the guise of combating
corruption that relies upon the GOP
members in the Senate not having a
conscience doesn't it well I think it
it's very hard to look at the evidence
that we've seen to date and and not
think that what you have here is an
impeachable offense remember this is
something that the founders were
incredibly concerned about the notion
that you'd have an executive who was
inviting foreign interference in US
affairs it's one of the reasons they
created the impeachment power in the
first place
and so this is one of these clear-cut
cases if if inviting a foreign power to
interfere in an American election isn't
impeachable it opens a question as to
what could possibly could be so do you
think the mean the president's gamble
may not pay off here if it does come to
a trial in in the Senate then we could
see Republican senators voting to
convict well I think it's interesting to
see what exactly will happen I think you
know there are a lot of predictions
going on now but there will be a moment
in which senators are forced assuming
that the House passes impeachment which
seems quite likely there'll be a moment
in which senators have to grapple with
the enormity of what Trump has done and
make a determination about sort of what
side of history they want to be on so
I'm really good to talk to you many
thanks indeed for being with us Sam
burger that vice president de demócrata
of democracy and Government Reform at
the Center for American Progress